hoy vamos a hablar un tema muy
interesante la pasada semana abordamos
el caso de donald trump
y ese hombre de negocios se suman que ha
convertido la campaña del partido
republicano en eeuu de campaña por la
nominación en una auténtica colección
des abruptos e insultos y delirios sin
embargo aunque de la distancia nos pueda
parecer lo contrario
donald trump no está solo en la carrera
por la nominación hs enrique aunque
algunos les parezca mentira hay vida más
fea del trump y hoy vamos a conocer a
los otros cuatro candidatos que aspiran
a la nominación republicana vamos con
ellos
hasta nevada el político con que más
fuerza se ha opuesto donald trump ha
sido de cruz el senador por texas de la
última legislatura no sólo es uno de los
líderes del partido republicano más
jóvenes sino también uno de los más
conservadores y es que en esta vorágine
por el extremismo en muchos casos el
populismo que ha inundado al partido
republicano de cruz está dispuesto a
liderar lo pero por la derecha
de hecho en su campaña por la nominación
se hace acompañar de un grupo de oración
y además pretende conseguir dicha
nominación a la candidatura a la casa
blanca al partido republicano con el
apoyo fundamentalmente del voto
evangelista
a
pero porque consideramos que te cruz es
uno de los políticos más conservadores
en primer lugar tendríamos que destacar
su oposición su obsesión por perseguir
la inmigración ilegal de hecho después
ha comprado prácticamente los argumentos
de donald trump al respecto quiere
deportar a más de 11 millones de
personas quiere construir el muro en la
frontera con méxico e incluso establecer
controles biométricos en los aeropuertos
y en todos los accesos al país para que
cuando alguien abandone eeuu en tiempo y
forma la policía pueda perseguir le y
por supuesto multiplicar el presupuesto
de las patrias fronterizas pero no sólo
es por la inmigración por lo que
caracteriza el conservadurismo de donald
trump es un furioso opositor al aborto
incluso en casos de violación se oponen
al matrimonio homosexual y quiere
aprovechar cualquier tipo de resquicios
para defender lo que denomina la familia
tradicional
por supuesto no quiere ni por asomo que
el estado pueda establecer ningún tipo
de limitación con las armas no es para
un ferviente defensor de el derecho a
portar armas se opone con todas las
fuerzas al obama care
y quiere pegarse con lo que él denomina
en el cartel de washington aquel
conglomerado formado por las élites del
partido democrático y partido
republicano que en sus propias palabras
ha secuestrado al pueblo americano bajo
una vorágine de impuestos regulaciones y
limitaciones a la libertad general y
además es todo un halcón del señor cruz
porque en política exterior dice que hay
que reforzar el papel de eeuu y lo que
considera reforzar el papel de eeuu
supone romper el acuerdo nuclear con
irán llevar tropas para enfrentarse o
aniquilar como él mismo dice al estado
islámico en materia económica el señor
cruz también es ortodoxo al respecto y
como buen conservador defiende recortar
todo tipo de gasto que no tenga carácter
militar porque aquí sí también es un
buen republicano y en línea con esta
vorágine de conservadurismo que ha
asolado o populismo diría yo que asoló
al patio republicano quería estar más y
más en armas y establecer lo que él
denomina un flat tax es un impuesto
único a empresas
la contribuyentes ya sean personas
físicas o jurídicas por cierto es hijo
de un cubano difunto nació en alberta
canadá algo que ha sido aprovechado por
sus enemigos los adversarios políticos
para cuestionar su legitimidad para ser
presidente de los eeuu como vemos un
político tremendamente conservador que a
pesar de estar mucho más preparado y ser
mucho más coherente que el señor donald
trump sin el cabo es considerado
encuesta en el prestigio no se queda
atrás a la hora de poner propuestas que
rompan con el marco de la política
americana el siguiente nuestra lista es
marco rubio
bueno marco rubio también es joven tiene
44 años y es un abogado de prestigio
actualmente es senador por el estado de
florida como decimos el tipo brillante
de hecho bueno en 2012 cuando romney se
posicionado para ser el candidato
republicano uno de los que barajó para
hacer vicepresidente con él fue marco
rubio políticamente hablando hay que
reconocer que ha sido un poco veleta fue
uno de los autores del proyecto razón a
la ley para tratar de conseguir la
ciudadanía a los 11 millones de
migrantes sin papeles que hay en todos
unidos y luego pues se sale de ese
proyecto y también se metió en el tea
party cuando aquello empezaba a crecer
en nuestro 2010 y ha dicho algunos
latinos no le había pancartas a uno que
decía o no marco rubio latino tea party
no es decir que se aclare no
bueno él es de origen cubano no sus
padres son cubanos y él siempre dijo en
su día que bueno pues que sus padres
emigraron a eeuu por motivo de fidel
castro que se descubrió que no que eso
no era cierto que los sus padres habían
imitado antes de que fidel castro-
llegar al poder es decir que huyeron de
la dictadura de batista bueno son
ilegales o bastante desgaste y lo que lo
que fue es pedir perdón y contrató a un
detective para que tratara de buscar la
verdad y dijo que le ayudó a cómo hacer
su su propia historia y se declara ahora
mismo católico fervientemente católico
cuando vienen en las vegas' pues con 13
años
a su familia le dijo yo porque no vamos
a realizar una que están en todos mis
amigos y parece muy interesante bueno
pues parece que yo no le gusta mucho a
su abuelo
intento llevar pero eso de que no podía
fumar y beber no le hace mucha gracia y
bueno pues al final le dijo a dijo a su
familia bueno pues no pasa nada y creo
que vamos a ver es católica no lo sé
criticando por ello pero bueno es un
dato desde luego muy muy curioso el
siguiente candidato de nuestra lista es
john cage y el actual gobernador de ohio
y al que muchos consideran como el
candidato más moderado de estas
elecciones y digo de estas elecciones
porque tradicionalmente que ha sido
considerado muy conservador
a diferencia de sus contricantes que si
tiene experiencia en la gestión política
y es que 2011 es gobernador en el estado
de ohio su política económica se
sustenta en congelar el gasto de
carácter no militar sobre todo el gasto
social de una redistribución de partidas
cuando se mediten recursos y bajar
impuestos de hecho ha sido conocido el
cambio que ha realizado en estadios ohio
donde no sólo ha conseguido terminar con
un déficit de 8 mil millones de dólares
sino al mismo tiempo bajar impuestos en
casi 5 mil millones y además a
diferencia de sus contrincantes es
partidario de una reforma migratoria que
otorgue el derecho a estar en eeuu a los
inmigrantes ilegales es decir
regularizarles y en política exterior no
quiere romper el pacto con irán y
considera que fue negativo no es
partidario de la negociación obama y le
ha reprobado pero tiene que una vez
firmado hay que respetarlo es un buen
aliado de israel y
si tienes planteamientos mucho más
moderados aún siendo muy conservador
probablemente si el marco político de
eeuu o todo el partido picado fuese
distinto que si hubiese tenido muchas
posibilidades de ser candidato a la
presidencia sin embargo hoy hay quien
dice que sólo continúa la carrera para
conseguir una nominación como
vicepresidente y para terminar nuestro
último candidato es ben carson
ha pasado próxima vez creando bastante
expectación porque como donald trump no
tiene experiencia política alguna y sus
declaraciones han sido un tanto
polémicas
y sus posiciones políticas no son tan
radicales como la de dos candidatos él
no estaba a favor de deportar
inmigrantes como pueden estar a otros
candidatos no es no está a favor de lo
cual quiere tampoco es decir estar
actualmente en contra de cualquier
estilo de sanidad pública de eeuu su
posición así mujeres ha ido decreciendo
empezó muy fuerte y había mucha
explicación sobre él pero al final ha
resultado ser un poco blues está
esperando a ver qué pasa un súper martes
y algunos atracciones incluso que bueno
pues que de momento hasta a ver si
pueden en algún libro también que nunca
está de más
bien pues como hemos dicho aún no hay
nada decidido es decir hay que esperar
todavía para saber quién va a hacer
finalmente el nominado pues en concert
trump como el hecho cruz rubio canson
casey no sabemos hay que esperar por
ejemplo la súper martes y tenemos por
delante el día 1 de marzo y bueno es
cierto que el día 15 el 15 de marzo
podremos saber si te amas finalmente y
derrotado si le echan de la de la
carrera cosa que yo personalmente espero
tienes cualquier duda cualquier
comentario cualquier persona que hacer
por favor no dudéis en hacerlo nos vemos
el próximo vídeo